nancy trudel se prépare à rouvrir son
salon de coiffure
tout est en place ou presque
point de vue matériel que nous on va
avoir besoin on atteint vraiment
l'association parler avec les
microbiologistes pour le matériel
nécessaire et surtout sécuritaire
partout au pays c'est une préoccupation
pour des entrepreneurs qui attendent
impatiemment le déconfinement quelle
sera la meilleure façon de se protéger
et de protéger ses clients
faudra-t-il absolument porter un masque
et des gants
si on ne peut pas respecter les deux
mètres de distance les compagnies
doivent savoir quelles sont les règles
et où elles pourront acheter le matériel
de protection selon la chambre de
commerce du canada
ça risque donc de prendre quelques
semaines avant qu'elle faisait tout ce
qu'il leur faut un et critères pour
commencé à rouvrir à certaines
industries va certainement être
d'assurer qu' il y assez de matériel de
protection individuelle pour pouvoir
faire le travail de façon 20 sont
sécuritaires et justin trudeau a mis en
garde les provinces
pas question de relâcher les mesures de
confinement si le risque de
contamination est élevé on ne devrait
pas ouvrir l'économie à aucun niveau si
on n'a pas en place les mesures pour
protéger les canadiens mais la santé
publique du canada n'a toujours pas de
critères clairs et précis et on commence
à discuter c'est peut-être que c'est
quoi les principaux et les critères
peut-être assouplira les allées les
meilleurs de santé publique même si
trudel assure qu'elle va suivre les
règles mais sa protection et celle de
ses clients passent d'abord par la
confiance des uns envers les autres
il ya des choses qui sont pas évidents
mais le lavage de mains oui le côté
sanitaire clients doivent de présenter
de symptômes et tout ça mais pour
réussir le déconfinement il faudra
augmenter le nombre de tests de
dépistage la santé publique a besoin de
bien suivre la progression de la maladie
pour mieux anticiper son évolution il
s'est fait le buzz en faisait radio
canada ottawa